en nuestro entorno podemos encontrar
representaciones de diferentes tipos de
funciones vamos a conocer algunas
situaciones en donde podemos encontrar
las funciones senos y cosenos como
recordarás las funciones seno y cosenos
pueden observarse a través de
movimientos simples y periódicos veamos
las siguientes situaciones para
identificar qué tipo de funciones
podemos encontrar
el movimiento de las olas del mar qué
tipo de función representar a seno o
cosenos pues todo depende desde qué
perspectiva las veamos representa una
función de seno si medimos las olas
desde el nivel del mar y gráfica más un
movimiento haciendo coincidir el punto
medio de la amplitud con el origen de
nuestro sistema coordinado de tal modo
que la onda pase por 0 0 es decir el
origen de la gráfica en cambio si
hacemos coincidir una de sus crestas con
el eje y la centramos respecto a su
amplitud tomando el eje x como centro
podemos verla como una función de coseno
ya que el valor máximo de ésta se
representa cuando el ángulo vale 0 pero
cuando usar una o la otra
la respuesta es según convenga de
acuerdo con la descripción de la onda
por ejemplo al describir el movimiento
de la compresión de un resorte afectado
por determinada masa considerando que
éste inicia cuando la onda está en su
máxima compresión observando la desde
este punto comenzamos a describir este
movimiento
el resorte toca la masa y no hay ningún
tipo de desplazamiento así que la
función que describiría este caso sería
seno sin embargo podrá describirse con
la función coseno cuando la masa afecta
al resorte provocando que su amplitud
crezca y se dé un desplazamiento hacia
la izquierda las funciones en y cosenos
son óptimas para estudiar el movimiento
armónico porque como recordarás son
periódicas son como un péndulo y
aumentan y disminuyen en un rango
específico 1 y menos 1 te invito a
continuar descubriendo en qué otras
situaciones puedes observar la presencia
de las funciones senos y cosenos